la brake è nei piedi che vorrei parlare
di questa sera è una vecchia gloriosa
idea quella del bricolage e vecchia
perché vi parlerò di evoluzione mi
occupo di evoluzione biologica e il
modello di cui vi parlo questa sera in
realtà un modello che ne abbiamo
imparato a scoprire nei dinosauri negli
uccelli mammiferi nelle specie sono
vissute tanti milioni di anni fa ma che
si applica anche a questioni che ci
riguardano da vicino è un problema che
angustia o il fondatore della mia
disciplina cioè charles darwin ed è un
problema che gli venne posto da un suo
avversario un problema apparentemente
semplice che potremmo porci anche noi
tutti qui si richiedesse
a che cosa servono le ali scommetto che
tutti voi rispondereste per volare le
gambe per camminare gli occhi per vedere
le orecchie per sentire e così via
se io poi vi dicessi ma allora quindi le
ali si sono evolute per volare
scommetto che forse presto abbastanza
convinti del fatto si è ovvio servono
per volare si sono evolute per volare
invece presto un errore madornale non
funziona così l'evoluzione le ali non si
sono evolute per volare lo dimostra
esattamente questa domanda perché
l'evoluzione un processo lento
continuativo è un processo che richiede
una costante cambiamento
quindi se adesso noi vediamo negli
uccelli un 100 per cento di un'ala a
cosa sarà mai servito l'inizio di una la
il 5 per cento di una la darwin non
poteva rispondere che la natura aveva
visto fin dall'inizio una l'ha già bella
che pronta altrimenti sarebbe un sorta
di designer di progettista intelligente
e invece l'assenza naturale e cieca non
vede nel futuro non può progettare vive
nel momento e non poteva nemmeno dire
che le ali sono sviluppate tutte in una
volta ci mise molti anni per rispondere
a questa questione
a questa obiezione e chiede tre risposte
diverse
e vi farò vedere le prime due la prima è
abbastanza comprensibile scontata la
seconda un po meno la terza è
sorprendente perché ce la siamo
dimenticata quasi per un secolo e mezzo
ci siamo accorti qualche anno fa che era
la risposta fonda
mentale non soltanto a questa domanda ma
a molte altre
allora la prima risposta che dire darwin
oggi noi potremmo rileggere in questa
chiave trattato la questione delle ali è
particolarmente interessante perché
sapete che le ali non le hanno inventate
gli uccelli ma le hanno inventate i
dinosauri perché dinosauri sono stati
erano gli antenati diretti delle celebri
non è vero che dinosauri si sono estinti
perché sono ancora là fuori che
sgambettano si nostri davanzale qui nei
campi nelle calli veneziane perché sono
diretti gli uccelli diretti discendenti
dei dinosauri compresi i piccioni e
tutta la grande gruppo degli uccelli
quindi i dinosauri hanno vissuto questa
transizione hanno imparato prima di
essere estinti in gran parte da una
catastrofe a riutilizzare gli arti
superiori per metterci sopra delle tende
le piume calitz servivano per la
termoregolazione cioè per proteggere il
calore del corpo
poi hanno imparato ad usarle per
bilanciarsi nella corsa e dopo molto
tempo sono diventate quelle che noi oggi
conosciamo come le ali cioè quelle che
servono per il volo battuto e possiamo
soltanto immaginare il primo proto
uccello che ha cominciato arrampicarsi
sui tronchi degli alberi ha scoperto che
poi bilancieri potevano anche servirgli
per fare il volo planato e poi magari da
una scogliera spiccare il volo per la
prima volta e conquistare un intera
nicchia ecologica nuova che è quella del
volo
noi ci siamo arrivati lì abbiamo copiati
soltanto poco più di un secolo fa o la
prima risposta che diede darwin era
legata all occhio questo è un altro
classico esempio che viene sempre fatto
l'occhio molto complesso e fatto di
tantissime parti che si collegano tra di
loro
se volete togliete una non è più uno che
non funziona più come ha fatto la
sezionatura le ad arrivare lì darwin
dieta e questa risposta che conosciamo
tutti un'implementazione graduale cioè
c'è un miglioramento funzionale e
progressivo avete un proto occhio che
comincia da una paziente un incavo con
particolare sensibilità alla luce una
membrana e poi si complessivi casa pre
di più finché diventa quello che noi
conosciamo come occhio in realtà sapete
questo processo che vedete qua è
successo 30 volte in natura
indipendentemente l'una dall'altra
cioè 30 volte animali diversi hanno
imparato ad avere a sviluppare gli occhi
il nostro è soltanto uno di questi pò
dei mammiferi e non è assolutamente il
più perfetto che è quello del polpo è il
miglior occhio che esiste in natura il
nostro è imperfetto dal punto di vista
ingegneristico quindi ok questa prima
risposta con qualche cautela sul fatto
che l'evoluzione non lavora come un
ingegnere appunto lavora come un
bricoleur come un artigiano riutilizza
il materiale che ha a disposizione
la seconda risposta di darwin diventa
ancora più sorprendente la prima non lo
soddisfa
ha capito che può valere per alcuni casi
ma pochi non per tutti sicuramente la
seconda è un altra risposta che ci siamo
dimenticati per lungo tempo non tutto
serve a qualcosa in natura cioè è
possibile dice darwin che in alcuni casi
ci siano delle strutture che si evolvono
per ragioni legate alla struttura per
esempio di un animale ma non la funzione
di quella struttura e fa il famoso
esempio delle strutture del cranio che è
bellissimo
lui lo dice nell'origine specie poi
questo è un esempio che ci siamo
dimenticati ma era molto importante
uno guarda le strutture del cranio negli
uccelli
scusate nei mammiferi in questo caso in
homo sapiens e si chiede ma a cosa
servono
e la risposta e servono a rendere
flessibile la testa il cranio
nel momento del parto quindi la rendono
un pochino capace di modi di muoversi in
modo tale da poter uscire lungo il
canale del parto solo che darvi sapeva
come sappiamo ancora oggi che le suture
cani ci sono anche negli uccelli e ne
rettili che devono soltanto uscire da un
nuovo questa è la dimostrazione che si
sono formate molto prima che nascesse
dei mammiferi per ragioni del tutto
indipendente legate a una simmetria di
sviluppo e poi nei mammiferi sono stati
riutilizzati in modo opportunista in
modo creativo da bricoleur per una
funzione completamente diversa che è
quello di passare nel canale del parto
questo è molto importante questa prima
risposta perché ci fa capire che la
natura è piena di inutilità non è vero
che tutto serve a qualcosa l'inutilità e
importante natura perché da un margine
di cambiamento da un margine di
ridondanza
la natura è sempre un po imperfetta e
dove c'è l'imperfezione c'è una promessa
di nuove storie di nuovo cambiamento non
dove c'è la perfezione assoluta e davì
impara anche ci insegna che dove ci sono
queste imperfezioni noi possiamo
riconoscere una parentela persona degli
organi inutili che ci fanno capire quali
sono i nostri antenati per esempio le
balene hanno ancora un inizio di bacino
che anche se non serve a niente ci sono
un sacco di serpenti che hanno ancora
degli abbozzi di arti di zampe che in
realtà non usano più e ci fanno capire
che discendono dalle lucertole
se volete essere ancora più convinti del
fatto che in natura non tutto serve a
qualcosa potete fare il famoso test
della cipolla che è stato proposto dal
mio collega amico ora in gregory
genetista che vi fa presente che se voi
pensate per esempio che nel genoma tutto
debba servire a qualcosa quindi che ogni
gene sia legato a un tratto che vi rende
complessi sappiate che la cipolla a un
genoma cinque volte più grande del
vostro e quindi con tutto rispetto per
la cipolla naturalmente però non è che
tanti geni voglia dire una grande
necessaria di intelligenza e complessità
quindi vedete che non conta in natura la
quantità di nodi e di una rete ma le
relazioni il numero di relazione che ci
sono all'interno di queste delle reti
del vivente e oggi abbiamo imparato che
questa è una acquisizione fondamentale
perché vedete questo maggiori esperti di
genomica oggi del capo del progetto è in
code stanno facendo l'enciclopedia di
tutti gli elementi del dna umano e anche
del trascrittoma cioè di tutto ciò che
viene trascritto dal genoma umano e dopo
anni di ricerche di uomo si è accorto
come capita spesso nella scienza questa
cosa meravigliosa della scienza
l'aspetto appassionante della scienza
che quello che pensavamo fosse la fine
di un progetto di ricerca cioè il
sequenziamento del genoma umano in
realtà era soltanto l'inizio di
tantissime nuove ricerche perché non
sapevamo di non sapere tantissime cose
il genoma vedete abbiamo parlato di
zhang tiene in passato di dna spazzatura
in realtà la metà fra dc
nella giungla di genoma è una giungla di
cui conosciamo pochissimo conosciamo
alcuni elementi di questa giungla ma
conosciamo molto poco le relazioni che
ci sono dentro questi elementi quindi
andare dentro il genoma e conoscerlo e
come infilarsi dentro una giungla
c'è un fatto che potrebbe non essere
soltanto una coincidenza in natura tutti
i sistemi più creativi cioè quelli che
sono stati capaci di produrre più novità
sono fatti così sono ridondanti sono
pieni delle azioni molto intrecciate con
pochi elementi ma molto intrecciati tra
di loro
poi c'è e questo è il punto siamo la
vera novità alla risposta numero 3
la risposta numero 3 è questa cioè come
si fa ad arrivare a un'ala come la
vediamo oggi ha un occhio a strutture
molto complesse come è stata capace
l'evoluzione di produrre grandi novità
lo ha fatto e oggi sappiamo quanto è
vero questo l'abbiamo scoperto in
tantissimi casi attraverso quella che
viene chiamata cooptazione funzionale
che vedete uno degli esempi più famose
che venne scoperto e spiegato da stephen
jay gould un grande evoluzionista che è
scomparso dieci anni fa e del pollice
del panda che cosa ha fatto il pan del
panda è un carnivoro un orsi della festa
nel posto sbagliato al momento sbagliato
cioè è in un posto in cui è obbligato è
stato obbligato per sopravvivere a fare
il vegetariano se si ciba di bambù
questo è il motivo per cui si ciba di
bambù dalla mattina alla sera perché
l'apporto proteico è incomparabilmente
più basso rispetto a quello che sarebbe
per lui naturale cioè la carne è un orso
è un orsi de come fa la natura a
rimaneggiare un orso che mangia bambù lo
fa in vari modi rimaneggiando
soprattutto il suo sistema digerente ma
lo fa anche in questo modo cioè provate
voi a prendere un orso e fagli afferrare
un bambù fa fatica
avete bisogno di un appiglio infatti il
panda a un sesto dito viene chiamato il
pollice del panda e che lo vedete qua
gli serve per afferrare il bambù ed è
praticamente un ossicino del polso che
viene ipertrofizza toe e sesamoide
radiale e diventa un sesto dita un
pollice che gli permette di afferrare il
bambù
quindi vuol dire che un ossicino del
polso può essere riutilizzato in
totalmente nuovo diventa un sesto dito e
questo ti permette di sopravvivere ti
permette di svolgere una funzione molto
importante poi ci sono altre stranezze
natura perché la natura ma spesso e
simmetrie perché i geni lavorano per
simmetrie nello sviluppo quindi siccome
il panda sviluppato un sesto dito né gli
arti superiori nelle mani diremmo noi ce
l'ha anche nei piedi anche se nei piedi
non serve assolutamente niente anzi è un
pochino di disturbo perché c'è un sesto
dito anche nei piedi quindi vedrete
anche questa è un'altra struttura che
non serve a niente un effetto
collaterale di un altro di un altro
processo
allora se è corretta questa spiegazione
vuol dire che quando raccontiamo le
storie evolutive dobbiamo stare molto
attenti a non fare l'errore che è stato
messo in parodia molto bene da kipling
nel 1902 no le storie proprio così dire
che oggi qualcosa serve a una certa
funzione quindi si è evoluto per quello
è una storia proprio così come quelle
delle favole per bambini che kipling e
racconta deliziosamente in queste in
questi racconti perché l'origine storica
di un tratto non sempre coincide con la
sua utilità attuale non sempre quello
che noi usiamo oggi si è evoluto per la
funzione che svolge oggi perché la
domanda come charlie scrive michael
disegno un grande biologo evoluzionista
domanda giusta per chi studia
l'evoluzione anche la creatività non è a
che cosa serve ma che cosa è successo
quali meccanismi ci hanno portato fino a
qui
questo meccanismo si chiama exaptation
ed è appunto la cooptazione e funzionale
una struttura che si è evoluta in un
ambiente ancestrale con una certa
funzione originaria o anche senza
nessuna funzione come le strutture del
cranio che vi ho fatto vedere prima e
poi viene cooptato per una utilità
attuale che può anche essere del tutto
differente se vuoi cliccate su google o
su sulle banche dati di paper
scientifici vedete che oggi l'ex up the
nation è usato è nato in biologia
evoluzionistica mai usato tantissimo e
linguistica pesato moltissimo dagli
studiosi di evoluzione delle tecnologie
perché hanno scoperto che questo
meccanismo di cooptazione funzionale è
fondamentale per capire per esempio come
si evolvono le tecnologie come si
diversificano e come avviene
l'innovazione non soltanto vedete nella
evoluzione
biologica e siccome siamo a venezia non
potevano scegliere il l'esempio che
steve j buddusò la prima volta per
spiegare le extension che sono i
pennacchi di san marco qui proprio il
san marco san marco di venezia perché
lui disse finora noi evoluzionisti
abbiamo fatto l'errore che potrebbe fare
un visitatore di san marco che entra
dentro vede queste opere d'arte
meravigliose osserva di come sono
distribuite nello spazio e vede per
esempio che in san marco come in tutte
le strutture in cui c'è una cupola
appoggiata su degli archi si sviluppano
vedete questi spazi triangolari che in
architettura si chiama pennacchi
spendersi in inglese e poi allora il
visitatore entra dentro la basilica san
marco vede che ci sono dentro queste
opere d'arte meravigliosa questi mosaici
splendenti fatti con allegorie in base 4
perfettamente adattate i pennacchi
allora uno potrebbe dire di sé gould che
i pennacchi sono lì per ospitare le
opere d'arte e quei mosaici che trovate
lì dentro
sarebbe un errore evidente perché tenna
chi ci sono comunque sono un effetto di
struttura se dovete prendere una cupola
appoggiarla su un arco avete quegli
spazi di risulta avete quell'effetto
strutturale poi l'ingegnosità
dell'artista è stata capace di dargli un
senso armonioso coordinando le opere
d'arte che sono state poi inserite
dentro questi pennacchi e che io adesso
vedo e mi danno l'impressione di una
armoniosa perfezione in realtà è stato
un gioco di bricolage e tra gli spazi
che c'erano a disposizione e l'allegoria
artistica che c'è dietro quindi la
natura è piena di pennacchi è piena di
strutture che sono più di quelle che
servono e poi la natura impara
riutilizzarle in un modo creativo e qual
è la struttura in natura più ricca di
pennacchi in assoluto più ricca di
spendere se il cervello umano ce l'ha
insegnato un grande genetista un premio
nobel france a giacobbe guardate cosa
scrive nel 77 dice io studio il cervello
da 20 anni vedo tutte le sue strutture
vedo che come è fatto e cerca una
neocorteccia dominante ci sono parti
vecchie e nuove intrecciate
ci sono vecchie aree cerebrali
riutilizzate per qualcosa di totalmente
nuovo
non è l'opera di un ingegnere ma è
l'opera di un bricolo il processo
evolutivo assomiglia molto a un
bricolage e penso che qui ci sia come
disse lo stesso giacobbe uno dei segreti
della creatività della natura e anche
dalla mente umana